think about the next 10,000 years think
about the last 10,000 years that's what
we call a long now the long now
foundation started in 1996 to get people
thinking seriously about the future and
our collective responsibility to those
distant generations today our foundation
has thousands of members from all across
the globe monuments scale projects and
micro scale projects and hundreds of
hours of talks by leading experts all
aimed at helping us seriously discuss
the next 10,000 years and our place
within the law now the long now
foundation is a nonprofit organization
and every donation every membership
directly impacts our ability to foster
long-term thinking about there's never
been a better time to join this
conversation help us continue this
important work with help from generous
donors and members like you long now can
continue to provide hope and inspiration
to long-term thinkers everywhere and
together we can cultivate a brighter
future for the next generation and the
next generation and the next generation
and the next generation and the next
generation
[Music]